never date a woman over the age of 30.
trust me you will live to regret it it
is a bad
investment it is a waste of time i'm
going to give you a lot of examples so
you can avoid the drama the headaches
and the migraines when it comes to
dealing with women
who are far past their prime what you
gotta understand about a woman what they
have to offer
it's two things number one their
fertility
number two their looks their beauty if a
woman is just giving that away for free
and just foregoing her settling down
with a quality guy all in her 20s
at her peak years why on earth
would you want to settle down with a
woman who's 32
35 40 50. it makes no sense
today's topic someone's admitted to this
video and i wanted to show abba and uh
it's great
it's really great it's cringe bro this
is so cringe
we're just starting at such a bad place
her fertility
her books
you know what they say whenever we start
bad there's only one way this up
listen there's a woman who turns 18
every single minute of the day
i don't know how old this man is but
what he just said was gotta be some of
the dumbest stuff
if you spend enough time talking to 18
year olds when you like nearing 30
that's suffering even 22. my mental
health was deteriorating trying to talk
to 18 year olds
the fact that this man is acting like
this is a prime solution is crazy to me
i would rather turn into a cat lady
i don't think that's possible i'd rather
turn into a cat lady than marry an 18
year old
a dead ass ah i agree because i value my
peace and quiet
i agree having an oh eighteen-year-old
mm-hmm
italy oh my god i've never had this food
over here
oh my god tick tock no it makes me no
in my house tick-tock in my house
are you crazy bella
she bring like a radio in my house start
playing hits
that yummy yum that yell and she dancing
like she
enjoy it rub rub
rub i was 26 i went on a date with 18
year old i had not suffered that much
in a conversation and i was like what
happened felonies are members of an
elite squad known as the special victims
unit
you're trying to calculate it because
they didn't you can't no i can't
it's just it makes me cringe too hard i
just not bro
listen morgan freeman i made out of
shawshank i'm not going back
so what he's talking about he's just
he's just operating from such a bad
place i think this is a very like
otto just like if that's the only two
things that you're looking for in a
woman then
it's just like just get concubines go to
a third world country just get a maid
that you bang and that's it that's
pretty much it you know what i mean but
what you're talking about
it's not what i'm looking for i don't
think it's interesting see the way he
thinks
i don't think it's wrong if you hold the
same values
right in that same token if you come
from a muslim background you want a
woman in hijab
who hasn't slept with anyone yeah you
know based off those values fine live
your best life
but don't go around talking about every
other woman who hasn't lived by those
values
as if they're invalid or disgusting
whatever they're just not for you
do you dig what i'm saying yeah that's
the separation i would yeah in that same
token there's some women who want a
traditional relationship
they don't want to work they don't want
to do any stuff and they want a man
who's going to take care of them
that's how some women want you and
that's okay but then don't talk about
other women or men who don't do that for
you as if they're invalid
that's it just everybody stay in your
lane but we don't have to disparage all
women who are over 30 and be like
you're past your prime you're pruning
you're doing all this stuff to me that
kind of rhetoric is just not conducive
towards acknowledging that people want
different things from different types of
relationships
you don't want a girl who's had any
experience in your life that's great
for your life maybe that's fine for mine
it's unacceptable
there's nothing worse than getting a bj
from a girl who doesn't know what she's
doing for me it makes me cringe
you know 22 25 interact and deal with
those women because
a lot of guys what they're doing is
they're saying well i'm 30 years old
so um i can settle down now and i want
to get a woman who's 30
or 35 or in my age range
it's not the same see you've probably
been grinding and working hard in your
20s right
you've been building yourself up you've
been doing the things you're supposed to
do
you have uh built your business you made
a lot of money maybe you made six
figures now or close to it
and that woman in her 20s you know what
she was doing she probably went to a
little college
but for the most part she's been living
her best life
she's been sleeping around i'm telling
you she's been dating around a lot of
dudes
bar hopping drinking doing drugs smoking
doing all types of things wearing her
body down
sleeping with this guy getting used and
abused
getting in a relationship with a lowlife
guy who has
no future she rejected hundreds upon
hundreds upon hundreds of men
who are good hard-working men who had a
good head on their shoulders
why i know plenty of women who have hit
around 30 and they've just been in three
long relationships
yeah i know some women who just don't be
out there dating and i do know someone
who fit that description
we all have different lived experiences
but me personally if i'd rather choose
someone who has been experienced that
hasn't been experienced i'll choose
someone who has experienced
but in the bedroom it's better in our
day-to-day life it's better i want
someone who's been through things
so that when i'm raising a child it's
somebody with character somebody who's
who's struggled a little bit i'm not
gonna grab
some 18 year old who's going to be
trying to figure out her life as she's
also raising a child like that's not
interesting to me
but again different strokes for
different folks
some people want that some people want
to get a 18 year old and they want to
train her
right like a little pet dragon
tamagotchi
right and that's okay if that's what you
want that's not what i want that's not
what i look for in a partner
i'm not looking for someone who i see as
being well below me
it's not interesting to me i got it
what this is who derek jackson is
talking about
this is his arch nemesis eric naxon
luke skywalker luke's guy walked to
darcympius
now all of a sudden she just sees the
light
and she's ready to settle down with the
good man and she's 32
30 35 40. all of a sudden don't you
think that's kind of crazy
no i don't i don't think that's kind of
crazy but gone through things and then
choosing to settle down later it's
literally what i did
yeah but it's different for women not
for me maybe for y'all
not for me no hey oh abby you just being
the same okay whatever
oh you just thought just do what's good
for you if you think this is good advice
for you that's fine
i'm not here to tell somebody that what
he's they're looking for in somebody is
wrong
right for a woman who wants to meet a
man who's making seven figures
and who has the stuff all together live
your best life
and if you feel like you can apply this
to you and you want to be with an 18
year old and it works for you
live your best life but it's not for me
so i just don't like the idea that he's
trying to speak for others and stuff
this is why you shouldn't no this is why
people think like you shouldn't
that's it also the reason why you don't
want to get a woman who's over 30
or a date or get a relationship with her
is because
she is unable to be molded
and trained yes i did say that what i
tell you about the pet dragon you you
what did i tell you i met dudes like
that yeah
and for them that works that's what it
is i would never want that
i agree because i can't i can't train
you into becoming an individual who can
stand by my side why would i i don't
have time to train people you know what
i'm saying about that word
train and hey
you're not going to hear me say that but
the other thing is like the thing is
like
i didn't learn what i liked in life by
training other people
people helped me discover that about
myself sometimes you think you know what
you want in somebody or you know some
aspects but then someone comes into your
life and they show you different things
you didn't know you wanted
so this idea that you're going to just
mold the person to me that's boring
for me but again some people are into
that
some girls want to be trained and some
of these want to train them choo-choo
live your best life a woman is supposed
to be a reflection
of her man so she's had a lot of
different bodies and she's come in
contact with different dudes and she's
carrying around these different spirits
and and and history with all these guys
when she gets with you what do you think
is going to happen
she's going to be lashing out for the
most part she's going to be really
closed off
she's going to have a hard exterior
listen i don't trust this dude's
experience because he's just talking
about his ass right now
yeah you don't think there's a cost for
men who engage in this kind of behavior
do you think it's only women who suffer
those kind of experiences what listen
i know dudes i know dudes who've done
their dirt there's a cost for them too
definitely if it's not physically within
their body with diseases and stuff like
that
it's exes it's baby daughters it's all
this other stuff
you think you think women are the only
one who can be tainted by this kind of
behavior
and i don't even know like the idea that
like just because you've been out there
or you've been dating that you're
somehow tainted this kind of like
puritanical society that we're trying to
build i'm not a big fan of i'm not
saying
be hedonistic and give in to every urge
that's not what i'm saying
but it always sounds like to a lot of
people like if you did anything
you're a little tainted stop and it
really comes from people that that
really
like this is there's a hypocrisy in this
where you do engage in that if you wanna
do to do
you're gonna need someone that does the
does so you can't be pointing fingers
when you're doing the same thing
yeah but uh on the key she's a lock yeah
and a lot of women in their 30s they try
to do they say well
uh i need a man who's going to be there
for me who's going to
want to prove to me that uh he's the
right guy for me
now i guarantee you in their 20s these
women never said that to all those loser
low-life guys or whatever dudes
they never had those dudes jump through
hoops and it's funny
they all of a sudden have standards they
all of a sudden
have a checklist of all the things they
want from a guy
yeah it's called experience that's
exactly what i went through
it's called experience you see what's
going on then you know what you don't
want
you know what you want you know what you
don't want after you know going through
guys go through the same thing you want
certain things at 20
and then by the time you hit 27 20 29
those things shift
yeah your standards change that's not so
like looking at women like they're
how come they want scares up everybody
gets standards as they grow
but they are far past their prime when
it comes to looks
their eggs are drying up and on top of
that for the most part they're
uncooperative
see if a woman wants to settle down with
you and be with you in her 30s
you best believe that she's either tired
of working
or the guys that she really wants don't
want to be with her or she just has
crazy
crazy expectations okay this is just his
opinion he has nothing to back any of
this up
so for me like this whole video is
boring he's just repeated what he's seen
on a bunch of other channels yeah the
same type of content
she passed her prom she's pruning out
guys
i don't know about y'all but a lot of
the older happy couples i see
it's not like everyone is the best
looker what's going to sustain you
what's going to keep you happy in life
especially later on years it's not the
looks
it's not all that stuff of course you
ideally want to be attracted to your
partner but it goes well beyond just the
looks part
and as you grow older i'm going to be
very honest with you that
whole department changes you don't look
at women for the same reasons that you
did when you're 20. absolutely if you
think i'm going into my relationships
trying to look for the best looking
woman
listen man been there done that slept
with the i did it
and guess what it's not gratifying i
don't go walk around like
damn [ __ ] you know what it's not that
big of a deal
you know what i do value peace and quiet
you know what i do value
somebody who's when they by my side i
feel like my home feels better
that has nothing to do with necessarily
with their looks of course i want to be
attracted to my partner that's always
going to be a thing that i'm going to
want
but this whole talk that he's having
about like past prime and all this stuff
i'm like man you got to see things in a
bigger
and a bigger mosaic that's such a basic
third world view
of how to view the opposite you gotta i
understand why this exists in
my home country right because you need
offspring you need a young wife to make
many kids
these are ideas and values that
understand for different parts
you're looking for different things
because the struggle is different out
here
both the men and the women often times
share the financial burden yeah they
both work a lot of times
in fact women out earning men in a lot
of situations so
if your environment is different the
things you're going to look for in your
partner are going to be different in
terms of necessities
right we don't have to worry about if
you think of like uh
the the the pyramid of the hierarchy of
neets oh maslow
yeah we don't have the same needs here
no that they have over there
definitely not and so it stands to
reason that when you're building a
family
and a partner you're not going to look
for those same basic things because when
i'm
thinking about them i'm thinking about
survival yeah definitely there's a
there's a survival thing that's right no
in in in haiti we say
like the donkey makes his uh
offspring so that they can rest their
back and that's pretty much what
happened in these countries where you
have a lot of kids
you have more kids and stuff like that
and stuff to work around and to
be able to handle stuff and even handle
other kids you know what i mean
i had to show you this because i don't
know if it was different in the realm of
the
dating realm or whatever what not if
it's something different you understand
what i'm saying
like i saw that and i was like wow it
feels a bit odd it feels a bit off
it feels a bit deep i say but then again
what the [ __ ] one no i don't know the
dating world like that so i have to show
it to you
and i'm glad that it's exactly what i
thought it was like
it's really old-school it feels grudgy
cringy
there's there's maybe i could have been
wrong
so i had to show it to you just to be
like what do you think about that
which brings me to my next point you
have to be careful
of these overnight gurus
these over it's not because you have a
camera that you have to listen to the
person that's going on yeah that didn't
lose us but at least we agreed that
we could be wrong but this is like
there's a lot of videos that i've seen
like that like a trickle down you know
when you go to the
youtube spiral and it spirals down and
it's not it's not necessarily it you
have to be able to use your brain this
is something
it looks weird just you know talk about
it and
open more your eyes and just listen to
some people you understand what i'm
saying but that's pretty much it i had
to show you it's you because i was like
okay this is off the thing that was
rubbing me the wrong way he's like
if they're over 30 and they're not a
relationship it's either because nobody
wants them
or they're just realizing now that
they're done with hookup or
maybe you just didn't find the right
person you want to build a family maybe
life happened
yeah life happened things whatever you
broke up with the other one and what
life happens there's there could be a
lot of possibilities you can't just
narrow it down to two yeah
anyways maybe you were once with someone
and and they passed away
and you're still recovering from that
there's all kinds of reasons why people
are single
at different points in their lives and
for you to just reduce it to like
you're a bad vegetable i think it's lazy
yeah the place you're thinking
it's lazy thinking yes so those are my
thoughts on it
um